players on your favorite online
personalities including ksi in the
sidemen EXO
keemstar Joella the f2 and many more on
blocks tuber upload videos gain a
following take on ksi to become the
champ just download box tumor available
in the App Store now last time we
thought yeah you said there was if I
forget the call-out login remainders for
that day to be honest but um it's not a
freeze on the world works me honestly it
feels like everything every time I've
interviewed you like the first time just
before you took a big break from YouTube
and like you seem like lost yeah I could
tell from a podcaster you were like
where do I go now I kind of do music but
it was you wouldn't like really
fulfilling what you've pulled potential
was and now it feels like you are
[__] mashing it you know I mean in a
good place right now
yeah like really lights I'd say hands
down 2018 it's not written like finished
the year but I think it has something
the bursary of mine really hundreds and
hundreds at what what do you feel like
it's gone into that year to make you
feel that way um I think physically I
felt the best ever
I like I feel so good about my body I
felt so good about the way I look
mentally I'm just on it like you know
like you know but everyone still has bad
days here and there but like I just I've
just been so happy about everything and
even like the people around me like
everyone's happy everyone's like in a
good spot everyone's just enjoying life
and like it's just bringing so much good
energy for me and I just I'm just guys
it's funny cuz like you're not a
professional boxing champion now but
you're living the life of that really
well the charm everyone treats you like
yeah
or anyone things out here like you know
you've got that lifestyle and like
that's how people talk to you now when
you're on top of the world yes and they
say you know it's hardly have the same
motivation once you become that mm-hmm
have you found any issues with that no
because I don't feel like I've reached
my goal yet I feel like I've just
we're not scraping the saffet I feel
like I've shown and done quiet law I
still have more to show and I still more
to do yeah and for me I feel like that's
the most important thing that's what
helps someone reach that well point that
they want to get to you may I think it's
class that you're always striving and
like you're not just satisfied but like
the first fight and I'll be honest I
suck yeah you know what Sydney go on I'm
gonna make this not easy I expected as I
said to Joe to do more but obviously the
occasion I think got to him and you know
it's by any means it's not easy like to
stand in front of all those people and
to perform in front of millions of our
minds it's gonna be hard
that's why I've alone and it's gonna be
even harder because everyone hates him
yeah for you that's your the hero this
time yeah yeah it's it's it's different
yeah like I don't know I know how I feel
about it because I'm always used to
being the villain
yeah I'm always used to being hated and
now all of them they're like ah okay
cool alright but in the eyes of many
people throughout this build-up like you
it feels have a loss to pay our war like
it feels like Logan I've had a few
people say it made quite a lot saying
like actually I'm kind of leaning
towards Logan in terms of the likability
because yeah I think it's because you
embrace that bad guy role you love it
just me I do love it
man I find it I find it weird being the
hero because I never see myself as a
hero I always feel like I'm just me I
just do what I do and you know people
gonna like me is people gonna hate me
it's just this way is yeah when
everyone's just always like all your
best you could this and that you're sick
and like I'm so hardly seeing any hate
it's just weird like I'm not doing
something right
if don't hate you then I feel like
you're not doing with them because
that's the way YouTube is like the
comment yeah yeah from day one back in
the day when you started like it was
always like if you're doing well you're
getting [__] that's a stick dance here
hundra said yeah that's right you had
like a baptism of fire in that respect
I know caught we've got a mutual friend
and Corden he said to me you kind of
predicted how this would all go at the
start to him he was kind of said to him
like I'm gonna lose the PR war in the
sense that Logan's gonna spin this
certain way yeah and I'm gonna maybe not
in the arena on fight labour in the eyes
of the rest of world you're gonna be the
bad guy yeah he really fought yeah yeah
yeah with my track I put in the line boy
you better get it one to ten the only
number send a medic boy by together beat
the man and out the [__] and jump and
read it boy about together cross you out
and turn the people empathetic so I
already know like people going to after
I beat Logan Paul people are gonna be
like ah you know I should kind of feel
bad for a little game like he's he's
litchi down in the dumps and at that
point he's gonna get a fanbase who are
diehard like through and through with
him because of that and they essentially
that's why I'm like saving his career
because of it
so it's it's kind of crazy but like do
you think his careers in need of that
like yeah hunter wiser I knew because
that will always not always be in the
back of the back of his like
prodigy or it always just be there and
he would never be able to you know reach
the point that he wants I don't think
you ever be able to reach the point that
he truly wanted to reach if what I'm not
video yeah what well yeah we're both
know the video he talking about
yeah were you asked to not speak about
that at the start of this yeah
yes did you agree of that I agree to it
but I I was like I'm still going to you
know step around it you know I'm not
going to talk about it directly but
indirectly I'm going to just you know
keep it looming
that's why I've the wig this why would
the pod me saying what I said with the
apology on the press conference and just
me doing you're doing these little
things just trying to poke the the press
content or interesting for me because
the first one I thought Logan came are
very confident hometown yes he had all
the crowd with him but I still thought
that you held your own and eventually
you started doing it you know you have
any feeling myself yeah and you started
getting into the groove a bit and then
when you brought the Hat oh and you
started cracking the jokes
if felt like Logan lost his temper a bit
yeah and it and for me as a fight fan
I'm like off you can't hold your head
together at that position
what is it gonna be like on fight night
you know what I mean did you pick that
up as well yeah so I realized that he
loses like he really I saw that he was
losing control and he hated that he
normally is the type of guy that loves
to have everything he loves to have
everything go his way he loves to always
win so when he was against someone that
was literally in his face
taking the piss out of him he was like
oh sure what's going on with the [__]
and at that moment he just panicked and
just decided to try me he had you put
his hands on you my hands on my mom he
lost yeah and Karina watching I think he
he realized that but he he's not gonna
admit it oh wait kinda I guess videos
video yeah and I'm pretty guys here
that's which I kind of appreciate that
he was just yeah yeah it's about but
even don't at the point where you first
met when he walked in the gym I fall
when he walked in that me well that gym
yeah probably took some balls on it
actually yeah yeah I don't know how what
his crew was like behind the camera but
you know I know you had yet big guys I'm
not as he has a few
boys as announcer but one thing
yeah his his like veins and his neck
were pulsing like I could say this it's
you know it's it's it's anger but it's
forced he isn't he
it's like his show he's trying to be a
person he isn't honey saying I knew I
was show in the boxing ring where do you
get that from that you think it's fought
what do you see in him ah I mean I've
just seen it in just how he is
I think they'll face the face the face
the face showed off quite a lot just how
he was he's like he was just extremely
fidgety nervous I did so I can see like
his lip was quivering like I mean it
doesn't really show it so you wash up
and you were saying a lot that during
the the truck between us because I kind
of felt like be honestly he was given
some good answers and he yeah he was
speaking quite he was coming up with
some funny remark to Maya but you kept
saying you're nervous I could say you're
nervous you don't like this to you yeah
and were you reading that [__] I didn't
see it I could see it in his whole body
he was just moving he was just like he
just wasn't comfortable huh and he I I
can tell like in certain situations he
hates it he hates it when things aren't
going his way
he's not in control when he's not in
control I know he was looking around
yeah yeah when he's not in control he
hates it and that's why in I ring when
he's not in control he's going to get
[__] a hundred percent your
uncontrollable that oh my god say you
know all right so the press conference
yeah
sitting there trying to no avail
you came in with just this relentless
mentality that you were going to wipe
the floor with them and did you ever
expect him to walk off like you did no
no I thought you're gonna take it like a
man and did you see him run off
I always saying Wow
so what are you gonna do in the boxing
ring you can't run off if I'm there
attacking you and you know you can't
take it or you can't handle it and if
you're struggling to you know not deal
with my power just my speed or you know
I'm too elusive for you know what you're
gonna do you're caught you're gonna just
run off you'll be like now I don't want
to do this
Jeff sort sort this out this is
ridiculous like these punches are hiring
me like locally in Blowing can't do that
Logan 100% hates it when he's not in
control and I see that and that's his
weakness you know you did all the same
things with Joe yes how mentally
obviously physically is another
conversation time yeah yeah you played a
lot of the same games you certainly got
rid of jaws Harrison yeah yeah do you
see any similarities or differences
between the two are you putting anything
together I thought we've Joe does a lot
more hatred I had a lot more hatred so I
feel like - yeah it was so personal
yeah it was so personal seems more like
business for me this is this is like
taking me and my team to a whole nother
level and I'm using Logan Paul to do
that yeah is that why you sort of
headhunted him he was yeah yeah because
he was the guy he was the top dog of
YouTube I mean was annoying I he was but
he is oh it was so I was like okay there
are some similarities between you two I
know that we may [__] hate it's a lot
but like it's yeah I mean there is like
we've all effort work out there yeah and
you know like how he how he is but I
mean like I've been doing this for so
long man what I mean is like for me what
makes a good YouTube depending on what
your tastes are um yeah you can do a lot
of different things yeah and you can
both turn your hands a different thing
yeah it seems anyway but no I I don't
know why now I leave that alone was
there for me being perfectly honest out
there
I'm wondering you obviously think you're
gonna win this fight
yeah how much harder will login be to
beat than Jawas Allah Allah
understand I'm not like I'm not gonna be
there like Logan's gonna be just as
easiest job I know Logan is gonna be a
lot harder maybe two three four times
five times as hot harder than Joe and
Wow you know what now I won't even say
that because Joe didn't really do much
so I'm sorry making a video your message
may make it a video the other day like
how everyone's like I'm not sure well
and he's just like just taking
absolutely no no no it's gonna be tough
yeah athletic background you know he's
got everything in his favor he's got the
height the reach you put me up a weight
you know it's the opposite of last time
yeah yeah and now he's got that and
you're gonna have to you know find your
way around or like yeah but that's why
with this camp it's been disgusting like
we've done ham like 100 percent way more
than Joel I've seen Carlos then Leon
beaten the foam yeah as a big do is a
very big dude what came the sparring
partners we talking about solid no it's
not more big dudes it's more people with
boxing experience and more skillful
people so it's not I'm not trying to
fight big lumps who can just learn hard
yeah I'm trying to be a more skillful
boxer because that's what's gonna be
important in this boxing match because
he will be able to just hit me and just
do all this and all that and for me I
feel like learning how to evade that and
just pop off and just just annoying
constantly just being in and out in and
out just showing my skill that's gonna
scare the [__] out of him and when that
happens he's fought and he's gonna know
his part yeah it I think this is going
to be a harder fight for you without a
doubt yeah yeah the world probably
accepts up um but I I love the challenge
man that respect is me mad like I've
been doing this YouTube thing for 10
plus years man
all my life always love you know just
pushing myself more and more this is not
just YouTube I mean literally you're
going in there against the dude who if
if he loves you haven't got your hands
up then yeah my career changes I say
yeah I'm they're like oh [__] I think
you're mentally prepared for that would
be further yeah yeah and I know you've
you've I'm I'm a tough guy man that's a
that's annoying thing because you didn't
really get to see it with me versus Joe
currently was definitely shirt on lose
yeah I guess but trust me especially in
this con man I mean I wish I wish we
properly filmed a lot of it but dude man
I've been hit with some big shot and I'm
dropping that I had just had that heart
man and it's hard to take that from me
it feels like your biggest weakness as
everyone knows was you didn't keep your
hands up a lot yes I covenant in this
fight like it's gonna be absolutely
essential for you to do that well I mean
weird
I mean we've trained to be a better
boxer so my hands will be up my hands
will be down but when my hands are down
he won't really hit me and when my hands
are up it's because I'm coming in close
and I'm [__] his [__] up so that
simple is that like I'm playing smart
everything is smart it's all tactical
I'm gonna be thinking when I'm in that
boxing ring I'm not gonna just be
swinging I'm not gonna be like oh [__]
ah you know I'm not I'm not afraid of
him
like he's afraid of me 100% and I know
that because he's I'm the champion and
he doesn't know what to expect from me
he's seen what he's seen but then when
he's in that ring and he sees something
completely different yeah he's gonna be
like oh okay this [__] he's in some
people's I had an advantage because if
he's got so much footage on you yes and
you've got ten seconds of TMZ
but even that 10-second chilled show
much but but you deliberately let out a
clip for Joe yeah he might have done the
same to you yeah he's playing you the
way you played Joe what if he is every
years then fair play fair play I mean
they won't matter when all this 25th
happens do you are you bothered by the
wrestling background however because
this is the boxing match in our
wrestling match yeah okay in the clinch
he might be able to do a few things but
I also know a few things as well yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if part of his
game promised to lean on you yeah yeah
yeah where you hope yo I wouldn't be
surprised if his game plan was to be
dirty like dirty paws yeah if he's there
like okay I ain't gonna be able to post
to this dude he's too good he might at
that moment just be like okay I might
have to play dirty I'm gonna have to
roughing him up back at the headshot you
know maybe a few low blows few diss and
that just a few tactics just to try and
piss me off but he won't piss me off
like I've been I've been training too
hard
am I like my psyche my mentality it's
just it's all on point are you good at
following that game practice Josh I was
chatting before we came in and Josh was
like um I'm confident and I'm providing
he just does what he's supposed to do as
if he's worried that you might just get
emotional not anything about you can I
mean the only time I get emotional is
when sorry I got I got angry when Jo
pushed me and I got angry when Logan
tried to rip up my banana so we're in
the boxing match and we're punching each
other I'm not gonna get angry I'm just
gonna be like well is this is it now
like you know you did all that [__]
then now it's time for you to face the
music last time we had a laugh about
what style Joe was coming in our said he
was mimic and Mike Tyson you love that
is there any sort of style you're
expecting from Logan anti Joshua that's
what I'm thinking I'm thinking he's
gonna be very regimented very like
direct straight you know textbook yeah
it's gonna know how to jab he's gonna
know how to throw across the base or the
hook he's gonna be
boom boom just rock-solid just for him
are you expect me to hit hard yeah how's
your son he's gonna hit hard
oh yeah come on of corporate look at
them oh yeah did you see that video he
did with Bradley Martin wait jabs him in
the face yeah yeah I thought it's funny
missed the first time yeah yeah I missed
the first by again I saw I saw that and
I was like those hours I lived in that
job and I saw that is such a textbook
job you you feel like your levels above
that I'm so I've been I've been sparring
against people who've been doing Boston
for years like years and years I haven't
I've been learning how to box for less
than a year let's see yeah like how many
moms like nine months yeah for me and if
you think Logan's going to [__] my [__]
up you got nothing to watch gone loose
yes the doll came on my podcast he sort
of stole a show a little bit yeah yeah
I'm sure you do what was it like being
in this cub with Fidel I was how's he
being training you for Logan yeah he's
been amazing he's always doin amazing
like we're boys man and he knows exactly
what I need to know to get to like get
through get past the final hurdle he
knows why he knows what to say he knows
what I need to work on I would see if
the fence was the biggest thing that we
worked on and I made sure that the fence
is on point and it is everything about
my defense is sick
if felt after watching jaws documentary
and yeah yours
you hit gold when you gotta sell
compared to what yeah sure god I [__]
yeah sure really I got really lucky
though with without like because I had
before him I had some other random
trainer and what would have happened you
know oh man I imported him in a tire
fight or close to fire
I think me meaning Fordow has just put
me in a completely different and you've
changed his life in a way as well as you
said on the podcast cuz yeah the
mayweather gym yeah he [__] this guy
open the mirror was like this heart man
when he's just doing her me it's bland
yeah bow it is so sick and when he
informed the people to VT as well I was
kind of worried I was like to me he's a
[__] animal it's like top for the
Maram he is a [__] demon yeah and he
he was just I was like home just to be
in but now who's 2020 at the time was
just [__] to be about the doll said
worse there isn't gonna be a rematch
like I'm training JJ you make sure there
is no worry yeah obviously not so oh
yeah it's why the camp is freed so yeah
he's I think or me no real a 20 row
that's why man this camp has been so
much harder than the Joe can obviously
have come through it like with flying
colors but [__] me it was it's been
tough and I think what's been that also
another talking is gaining weight and
I'm putting on weight but still being
able to move just as good still be able
to that part of the strategy though the
way was that obviously yeah a deal with
flow out sighs I know so cuz you were
put in the cutting equipment that was
Joey I was just got caught in those
blasts with Logan obviously he's a
bigger guy so I need to you know have a
few more kgs just to make sure that it's
not like he hits me I'm Dallas
[__] I'm just constant you put a lot of
importance on wait last time I remember
it it away in yes when Joe got on the
scales you openly laughed and said
that's a weekly yeah he has no chance
yeah but you're gonna be coming in
probably the exact same marching away
from Logan yeah but now you're saying
it doesn't matter no no no obviously it
does not not that sorry the dolls saying
it doesn't matter well I mean I think
what I was wrong because it does matter
it does matter a lot so I feel like
because of that if he does come in
heavier we just changed our plan to plan
B so there's a 9a and this plan B so he
comes in Wow
if he comes in similar to me plan a if
he comes in like way more heavier Plan B
and then we just worth that I mean maybe
I've missed quoted Vdara I think what
Vidal was meaning to me was if there was
20 kilograms difference then we're told
oh yeah but then then that's just what
he said to me was boxing skill wise
you've gone and yes that's all that's
always but it's interesting to say that
this is oh there's a plan for me yeah
yeah obviously because you know he's the
big guy I'm not gonna just stand in
front of him and just take bangs like
yeah I could slip this list that but you
know he obviously he's gonna do damage
so if I you know do I need to do I'll
[__] him up and he'll just be like what
the [__] going on and before you know
it those big arms so didn't go real
heavy you mentioned this in the face off
with him yeah the gloves are off
you said you're throwing a lot of
unnecessary shots there yeah when I
watch it I was like he was like yeah a
lot of punches awkward landing it and
not that once again makes me think is
this is this that he's putting that over
there cuz he wants you to say that
generally it's hard to tell yeah but
this footwork did look this and them
yeah that's what I mean I was gonna say
like he's like with that clip it shows
like there's a lot of positive like
shows he's got power he shows that he's
got that left hook so he's making sure
that my right hands up you know he wants
to make sure that would you call it his
footwork for a wrestler [__] hell man
I wasn't expecting that and I was like
okay cool
we'll take that into account and just
all these things were just taking it
into account and then when it gets the
ring it's like okay it's game time
moving but without well a fight and my
opinion are you change I are three
obviously I was looking is a great
youtuber yeah
no YouTube grip but when you walk to
that ring with the calmness that you did
yeah this guy is something different
yeah and like you had for your first
ever perfect like first of all a big
fight in front of a crowd that babe yes
it was like McGregor confidence like I
was I was impressed I got salt it's
genuinely I mean obviously I was done I
know you were I know you were just
fighting Joe
oh yeah the point is is anyone to go
into that situation would would have
been most people 99% and would have been
a lot more stress though yeah worried
about that and I was like more so than
the boxing skills I was more impressed
with how calm you were like yeah I came
away feeling like [__] me this guy's got
ice in his veins so yeah you don't it
takes a lot for you to go [__] yeah
nervy yes and from the first press
convert Abbott did with you I remember
album have you seen all these people me
like [__] me I've never done only this
before and then you're just like it's
nothing what I mean for me
what boosts me is the occasion the
occasion always boosts me like when
there's pressure when there's like eyes
on me I just do better man like even
when I spa when there's more people
there watching me I perform better and
when there's a crowd going to one [__]
him up and all that
I just it boosts me man I love it I like
the energy I don't know I meet all my
energy all the chakras sound like some
but I just it just fulfills me and it
just boosts me and this makes me just
food just better and just make me what
yeah because a lot of people before they
go to the ring like I've heard
professional fighter so yeah 50 invites
throwing up yeah I'll be I mean like
research and fighters for decade like
the confidence you have is not normal it
is not normal like jananam say okay well
you were you even a little bit before
you did the ring walk with voila were
you even a little bit like
well I mean what were you feeling the
only time I was I thought me was can't
lose where you saw me in the blue hoodie
when I woke up in a blue hoodie and all
that but I didn't really show it and
can't lose what boosted me was when I
saw the livestream
I saw the livestream I saw the people
there I saw my mates you know you know
what sue it up looking fake you know
like I was with I saw you I saw everyone
I was there I I'm guest this looks
insane yeah and I can't wait to go in
front of them and show them who's the
boss are you aware that you're that
sounds [__] but you're making history
like you're like are you aware like one
day people are going to look like the
new truth they surveillance was more
than a wall oven because yeah this is
seen as two kings and the internet go
and and it like you really like them the
biggest and the UK's biggest in America
and as much as I then want your websites
are going to compare this to me we know
it's not McGregor I mean yeah but in the
world of YouTube users are doing
something that will probably never
happen again like mommy even after login
there's not many avenues to court yeah
yeah he's the biggest issue about who
physically can compete with you yes and
make a compelling much of that everyone
wants us yeah like you're gonna do the
numbers are gonna be in me as like yeah
are you
is this about legacy for you on YouTube
or is this just are you just making this
up as you go along and same where it
takes you know what a question tom here
for what I quess know I know you're you
you say you walk like you talk the talk
you walk the walk or warp in a hell of a
[__] walk right now like because
YouTube's us this baby but like you're
doing [__] that is gonna in 50 years the
way we look back on you know grating the
players whatever like people who are
obsessed with YouTube down the road are
gonna look back when people like this
event yeah Wow like they did that you
know I'm I don't think it's I mean it's
like I don't legacy I don't I thought I
just do it because I just do it I don't
know it's weird like I just I always
just want for me
I just want to see how much more I can
do I always want to see what you know
what I'm capable of like seeing like for
me breaking down the power of ten little
people saying you can't do this you
can't do that I love telling people now
[__] you I'm gonna do that and I'm gonna
do it well that's just how I've always
been and it's not about I want people to
remember me it's not about me trying to
be this big shot or whatever I'm just
doing me because I want to do it for
myself and I just want I guess I I mean
it's cool that people look up to me and
I think it's cool that people are
inspired you know you can spell yeah but
I mean I've just you know I started this
all as a kid playing games and you know
it just puts being like oh you know I
want I want this to be my career and
then you know like I always had people
telling me you can never make money
playing and you can't do this you can't
do that and then I always just told
everyone no I'm going to make this
happen I'm proving people wrong it's
always just being my thing and I I don't
know I think for me now it's all about
making sure everyone else is just
everyone else is good like like that's
why I'm like with the Dow I know a lot
of people who would have been in my
situation with it being like yo Vidal
got way too much screen time you over
down look too good he's like
overshadowing me blah blah blah blah but
for me I'm there like I'm I'm gassed
I'm gassed up with now he's got such a
platform already on it he hasn't even
had one fight and I know like you know
his first fights gonna be that's what I
know he's gonna be bigger than actually
Joshua bigger than all these boxes
because he's started from sucked from a
place that no one started from and he's
already one of the biggest hypes and he
hasn't even watched he hasn't even
fought yet it's crazy and like even with
the side man and my bro
and you know my family just saw hey you
know for me like I've always just I
always just want everyone to do well you
even
you're even you help that's just it even
with like the the FIFA community with
the YouTube community like any any
little bit I can't do I'm always there
to just try to help people even people
who hate me like I met is his name I
don't know his youtube name Alex
I mean it's I'm ice yeah so he's made
videos like hate on me and saying this
than that but I've always just been yeah
I went to him use that the would you
call a
he was me Melissa's plus-one and yeah
and I was I just talked to him at yeah
and he was our yard just do this blah
blah blah I was like oh it's cool like
you can keep doing I understand why
you're making videos hanging me because
it's your way to come up it's just how
you need to do it like he was doing FIFA
videos full-time and got nowhere
and then as soon as he started making
controversial videos he started making
you know you start making the name
because that's not bother you at all
when our man come on man like there's so
much of the world we need to just share
it rather than just be selfish so I know
that's all that's that's not for me
that's always how it's been like it's
not about legacy it's not about do it
you know trying to be this name way it's
just about just making sure everyone is
having a good time man and fulfilling
stuff for myself make you know proving
people wrong and yeah no child no
Jennifer I know you're pretty well now
yeah and everything you just said is
footman true you mentioned your brother
yes he's fighting the same night no for
me are you gonna watch that fight
because you're gonna be ready a little
yeah watch it I'll watch her of course
you know he's got a hell of a challenge
ahead of him the Jake also has a size
advantage yeah on him theoretically
speaker and obviously if he wins great
let's go out yes I do my with fine if it
doesn't go that way and then say he
loses badly
yeah you've got a watch that are you
gonna be able to men
we removed that from your mind and
Hualien do you're jealous
how sure are you that I'm 100% sure it's
because like I've already fought the
worst you've accepted yeah yeah it's all
in your head is accept the worst yeah
and if anything else happens that's
great but this is yeah yeah so happen
that's why I mean if I you know I might
not know his point like anything else is
is the bonus and that's it like if he
fights well but loses that's a bonus if
he wins that's a bonus if he loses it is
what it is and I'll be there to company
you know come for him and just be like
unlock you man let me do my fight we
[__] this guy up and then you know we
can chat in the after pie and then you
know I sort of you know we're still
gonna be living good you know so I mean
like yeah I think when I when I talked
about the well I fight I thought about
you guys and I thought when I lose like
the people who love you are still gonna
love you
I like then that's when you realize who
your real friends are yeah when when you
lose if everyone just pieces out you
know they're not real friends but the
people who are you know there to support
you even after you lose their real
friends have you thought about what if
you should lose how things would play
out in your career I'm not nothing
I'm not is doesn't that's the thing with
me like when I'm saying this is
happening it's happening whether anyone
likes or not so if someone says no this
is gonna happen no this is this all my
life it's been like this and it's not
going to change
have you ever met anyone lately Logan
like if you ever cuz he's a pretty
different type of guy I when I look at
you both I see two really successful I
with you and Joe I found that there was
a clear difference yeah where because
you made jaws career by his own
admission where is with you and Logan
you've had similar rises in your own
countries and it's almost like these two
like stars are gonna collide and a lot
of people will see you as equal Simula
because you've always worn you've always
gotten your own where you've always
six-year and everything
have done and I'm practice is I'm sure
he has the same mainstay as the way
you're talking right now what what sets
your state of mind
I don't thought was I don't think he
does have the same mind sighs really I
think he wants to have the same mind
says me but he he physically can't
and it's because yeah it just hasn't
been doing it as long as me I've been
doing this whole YouTube thing for so
long way longer than most people on
YouTube who is still doing well today
so he hasn't he he doesn't I feel like
he still doesn't get it he just roast
the fame so quick and then he hasn't
ever tried to sustain it to the you know
to a level he's always just been like
okay that it's he's just done that
didn't it I feel like he like isn't on
the similar mindset to me you the way
you're talking I'm picking up as if you
feel like when I lose for example you
would always find a way whereas it feels
that you're saying he saw got one way
yeah he's kind of put himself in a box
when it comes to if he loses he's just
they're like oh I can't be that much of
man anymore I can't be you know this I
can't say [__] like there's someone
who's gonna be better than me and I
think that's gonna eat him up
really him up so much man especially
when he loses he's going to he's going
to [__] and destroy him because it's
visible yeah so on Rabia shine provide
of being assigned type away and then for
someone who's smaller a smaller guy to
be um and that's gonna really like just
not compute in his head well you know
he'll get back here he'll be back I'm
sure I'm sure that's why I'm there like
your boy I want a rematch 100% and he
will train like a machine he will be so
set to [__] my [__] up he will probably
put aside everything be like February
March April I don't give a [__] I'm
going to [__] dish
boy ksi and that's just gonna be his
mindset and then obviouly much really
good yeah go for it let's do it let's do
it I'm ready man I'm ready I'm ready bro
it's good it's gonna be easy
August 25th and it's gonna be easy
wherever the [__] we do it the next
simple as that man I final fight
prediction mate what what happened for
one for round four that's why I want it
that's why I want to end him round one
he's gonna be nervous he's gonna be like
[__] okay this is happening and he's
good wow this is why he's thinking all
this I'm jabbing the [__] out of him but
he's gonna try and count on me I'm too
quick I'm too quick okay he's gonna be
okay cool round two let me rush him a
bit let me come towards him and wrong
answer I'm there again [__] your
shell because this is what I want I want
to get close I don't want to play the
long range game but I can play the long
range game as well I can play any other
[__] game you want round three I'm
gonna be tired Mohammad can have a [__]
okay he's still like bouncing around now
I'm talking to him
now I'm getting in his head while worth
fighting and he's like [__]
this guy is talking to me he's not even
tired what what the [__] is this I'm
[__] knocking and you know he's just
been beating me around the bush left
right and centre [__] I'm gonna play
day I'm not gonna get me I'm too good
for this round four hit hit hit our
standing count hit hit hit and drop he's
getting dropped 100%
well that's pretty detailed explanation
well hadn't it there we go thanks for
your time
appreciate it I'm not the fight I see
you next year and do the same if we got
the rematch just every other rumors yeah
hopefully if it every do have I been to
America if I could see and I come to
America I saw hey she has met
thanks very much appreciate it on the
system all the best thank you when
people are tweeting at you you can't do
[__] about it you have to accept the
fact that people hate you when twenty
thousand people are booing me I can do
something about it that's gonna be fun